I'm sociologist and my my husband is a
doctor and said we are the people who
stands see more than nine hours and
nobody even it's a hard story when I
remember start to crying and so we try
to travel from true here to Union
accident now we are the pollen pollen
it's a crush on the stone and it's fun
doing it bump we a down on suicide the
same so we save our cell phones the
stones it's Tony's to a small stone
don't we called all their the chalky
polish to save as they didn't came after
nine hours when they can as they just
save us by helicopter only me and my son
and some others people and so it was a
hard story you survived yes but we try
again two times even the first time they
put us in a jail after we save us they
put us in jail and we tried again they
catch us when we start to travel also
then we started for the third time it
was very hard and we came in this
knowing it was snowing and we came we
arrived actually it's me Tina Jenna it
was my ears on thursday the first he was
a first year and so we came here now we
wanted to how are you feeling now I'm
feeling yeah I appreciate you I
appreciate you it was very hard to come
here even it's cold it's freezing
outside but we cannot live there they
change our life to change our country
you know if we start to live in here or
here it's not easy to leave this party
or this party they fighting but were our
about our fight is not my child we need
the like water we need the food is
there's nothing over there and
everything is expensive it's not safe to
leave
even with you know it's not a lot for us
without covering we have to cover our
hair we have to change our religion it's
not easy for us